Comparing this to what we have up here, P the principal belongs right here.
Now, what goes here is the interest rate that we use every time interest is
compounded. This is equal to the annual interest rate, r, divided by n, the
number of times interest is compounded per year. We can see that that's what we
have up here. We have a 3% annual rate. 0.03 divided by 2, which gives us this
number. Great, we're really close. Now what belongs in the exponent? We know
that what needs to go here is the total number of times that interest has been
compounded. It's compounded n times for every t years. So, that means that the
total number of compoundings is just nt. There we go, we have a formula that
should be pretty easy to use. And I hope, more than anything else, that this
makes sense.